In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 22, on which we commemorate the Holy
Hyromarter, Fokas of Sinope, Bishop and Wonderworker.
On the 22nd of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Hyromarter Fokas, the Wonderworker.
St. Fokas was born in the city of Sinope on the coast of the Black Sea.
His father was a shipbuilder called Pampilius, and his mother's name was Mary.
God gave him the grace of working miracles from the moment he escaped the clutches of paganism, until his death.
He eventually became Bishop of Sinope, bringing many pagans to the true faith by his inspired words and miracles.
One day, a dove set a crown of flowers on his head and said, addressing him in a human voice.
A cup is prepared for you that you must now drink.
In this way, God showed St. Fokas that the time of martyrdom had come.
He went straight away to the Governor of Africa and boldly confessed Christ, true God and true man.
Africa was blasphemed, the name of Christ and had St. Fokas tortured, whereupon he and his soldiers were struck dead by a violent earthquake.
The Governor's wife asked the saint to raise them up again, which in the image of the merciful creator he did by his prayer.
He was later brought before the Emperor Trajan in the years 98 through 117, who had him flayed and thrown into an overheated bath, where he gave up his spirit to God.
After his death, St. Fokas continued to work many miracles for those who with faith called for his help.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.